So according to Newton's third law, forces always exists in equal and opposite pairs.
So that means as the earth pulls the skydiver down, the skydiver also pulls the earth up.
We know that a skydiver moves down as she falls, but my question is,
"By how much does the earth move up during the 10-minute skydive?"
To answer this question, let's assume our skydiver has a mass of 65 kg
and the earth has a mass of 6x10Â²â´ kg.
Now here I have used scientific notation and if you're not familiar with what this means
you should check out the link below this video to learn more about it.
It's not too hard. Basically, it means that this is a 6 followed by 24 zeros.
Use your knowledge of Newton's third law of motion and these numbers to answer this question.
Enter your answer in scientific notation
by putting your base number here and the exponent up in this box.